[Music]
you saw this right oh oh oh oh man oh
man this kind of in line with the
redditor things so I feel like's this
this is in theme redit lies oh this is a
goodd lies so this Reddit lies so many
wait so it's a lie got to be anyways
whatever many have heard many have heard
of the redditor who couldn't open his
soil bottle few have seen the mod
response to the people who ridiculed it
that's somehow even more cringeworthy so
on the soilent subreddit I guess first
of
all why are you how much discussion is
there to be had about
soilent um is anyone noticing their
belly button getting
[Laughter]
smaller so some dude says I I guess the
joke here is that like it's a soy boy
thing or whatever right right if you
drink a lot of so soy it has estrogen in
it or whatever right so I so this guy
says I legitimately hurt my hand trying
to get the bottle open the of soilent
he's talking about so much so that I had
to start asking my co-workers to open
them for me so happy my new bottle
opener finally arrive this can't be real
dude I'm just being at the gym just
taking a swig you're soilent hey man do
you mind putting the 10B plates on my
barbell real
quick did you hand me the fives you
could you help me just could you spot me
with
the could you spot me with the fives
people were like like dunking on this
guy obviously cuz it's like if you if
you can't open a bottle of soent stop
drinking soilent I guess that's there's
no way bro so then so but people like
people feel some type of way about
soilent because I guess it helps a lot
of people right right if you eat a lot
of fast food and your diet is really
shitty this is like a I guess a easy way
for people to kind of like improve their
diet oh
what get nutrients yeah and like not eat
as much [__] because all you do is you
eat soilent I also like how all the um
you know optimal living guys pretend
like home-cooked food from the store has
actual nutrients in it either like in
terms of like our farming there are like
no minerals or anything in the actual
ground you know what I mean yeah like
that's why when you go to Europe and you
eat beef you're [__] your brains out
cuz it has all these like minerals and
nutrients that aren't in American food
okay you know at least that's my theory
you're saying our food is [__] up yeah
our food is horrendous definitely is
[__] up that's why all these [__]
alpha male guys got to take 40 Vitamins
because they can't get it naturally
they're like so if you eat six bags of
broccoli you can get one gram of boron
yeah yeah
Boron for the past six months This
Thread has been a target of ridicule and
Mayes of the darkest variety no the
danst oh Mayes what the hell is a
mayay of the danst variet what the hell
even is that no what the hell is that
even what's a mayay can you Google mayay
oh no what is it oh no it's like he's
saying memes oh no no dude like a
mispronunciation of take this guy oh
like dank memes take this guy [__] take
this guy out back and shoot
him look at my nice mayay there's Doge
and that boy in it
that just made me want to like put my
head on a table
saw yeah that's good
man I don't know why like a Banda ah man
I love it he said May me like
[Music]
that splitting I don't know what it is
when I re am I the only one that gets
that viseral when you read something
cringe like is it just me or do you
picture like violent things happen
happening to yourself no I get that too
like some things I read and I just look
up from my phone and I just dream of a
cinder block falling through my
skull you're going just perfectly
killing me
dude
perfectly like piano landing on you yeah
yeah yeah like my head is that dude from
scanners blowing up it's just that same
you know I'm just there and
just for the past
six months this threat has been the
target of ridicule and Mayes of the
dankest
variety
yeah
um yeah Mayes of the danst variety I
must thank each and every one of you who
thought you were bringing something
original to the table and giving the
mods and I an excuse to wield the
banhammer with such Wild aband
keep with such wild abandon on the
stupid seriously who comments in a month
old thread like this oh right over a
hundred of
you thanks for that because you made it
easy for us to remove people whose sole
purpose is to invoke internet [__]
watery oh that one hurt that [__]
hurt hi could I just get on the uh the
band saw real
quick
is that
splitting hi could you just hold that
cir saw up I'm just going to run at it
thanks is that that's a band saw right
okay it's it's pretty good
yeah is it you mind if I hop on the
table saw real
quick
yeah so anyways keep it
going hi is oh is that is the lathe
running I'm just going to fall into
it what's that thing that like the two
things that
crushes uh you know like the two like
massive metal like thing with teeth and
it goes oh yeah yeah thing that Mr to
destroy that yeah yeah yeah oh dude that
thing cool that's the pit right yeah
yeah that thing
would no dude I don't think it would
jiggle I think it'd be more
like I think it would just like twist
and jerk you like yeah
yeah twist and jerk me no I think that'd
be one of those like your feet going in
and you're just excruciate and you pass
out and you're actually you would just
you would fall on and roll into the
other
one it just man imagine your head going
through that just
oh dude you're getting too real it's all
right all right getting too good at the
ACT yet yeah it's just a [__]
like
sorry sorry sorry keep going whose sole
purpose is to invoke internet [__]
watery you spread a thread thinking you
were doing the ridiculing and instead
brought more people into our little
corner of the internet who actually saw
something useful and valuable you
further popularize one of many ways
people can try for a better diet discuss
Health Sciences eat less fast food to
actually taking the dive and trying out
one of the many varieties of engineered
Foods my only regret is not being a paid
shill so I could have some so I could
have reaped some of the profits likely
gained so thank you for making our work
as volunteers so much easier sincerely
your [__]
daddy